hi in this video I'll talk about the
lineage commitment of the t-cells as we
know t-cells and b-cells are the
important component of the adaptive
immune system and they are born inside
the bone marrow from the hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell like matter
particularly potent stem cell give rise
to lymphoid progenitor now the lymphoid
progenitor in one hand side can give
rise to b-cells in sequential steps like
lead pre b-cell pre b-cell and been the
immature b-cell eventually these
immature b-cells would leave the bone
marrow and go to the peripheral lymphoid
organs like lymph node on other hand
side the same lymphoid progenitor can
give rise to t-cell precursor which
would eventually migrate out from the
bone marrow and the t-cell precursor
would go to the thymus where as the
b-cell precursor or BSL immature b-cell
goes to the lymph nodes now inside the
thymus t-cell development take place the
undergoes tymek training and
sequentially they are filtered out or
they're screened for their ability but
today's topic is to understand that how
the lineage commitment takes place how
the common lymphoid progenitor decide
when to become a t-cell or when to
become a b-cell so it turns out the
t-cell precursor that is moving out from
the bone marrow is not committed yet
towards a t-cell lineage though it is
called a t-cell precursor but is not
committed to the lineage eventually
there are some cases where it can even
become NK cells dendritic cells or even
b-cells
so the question comes how does this
b-cell lineage commitment take place
what at the molecule mechanism
underlying it so we have to understand
that from hematopoietic pluripotent stem
cell there are two type of different
progeny ters and from the common
lymphoid progenitor there are two
different lineages produced and two
lineages are produced in different
anatomical location like one in the bone
marrow and lymph node and one in the
thymus so a key aspect is to look at the
thymus and understand how the lineage
commitment takes place in the time as
what are the molecular if
going on in the timeless which leads to
a t-cell lineage commitment now it turns
out that there are like several genetic
studies where there is not one
gain-of-function Mouse in that not one
gain-of-function Mouse inside the bone
marrow all the lymphoid progenitor cell
has become a t-cell precursor literally
these mice don't have any B cell in the
bone marrow which is ultra weird now
second conditional knockout of notch one
give rise to b-cells in the thymus I
mean normally in the time as you would
expect t-cells but the in case of not
one conditional knockout you would say
b-cells in the thymus which is unusual
so these two genetic experiments in
combination tells us that not signalling
has an essential role to play in terms
of T cell lineage commitment high level
of not signalling allows the T cell
precursor to be committed into the notch
into the T cell lineage whereas reducing
the not signaling would allow it to be
in a B cell lineage so the critical
balance of not signalling is important
for T cell versus B cell lineage
commitment now let's look at inside the
thymus what happens in an endogenous
situation such that it leads to a T cell
lineage commitment now we all know that
after migrating inside the thymus these
T cells would go to the sub capsular
region and from them there they would
descend down to the cortex at a double-
stage where it has both neither the cd4
or cd8 co-receptors now at this stage
the T cells Express knotch
whereas the not ligand is expressed by
the tymek epithelial cells now people
were trying to culture B cells and they
succeeded in that that they found out
that if you if they first played a
monolayer of bone marrow stromal cell on
top of that they can eventually make the
B cells but
that time there was no T cell culture
model and it was very difficult to
culture T cells only option is to have a
organized repeat culture of the whole
thymus so why he could not culture T
cells but one breakthrough experiment
happens which also tells us about the
lineage commitment now in this small
layer of bone marrow derived stromal
cells if you overexpress the notch
ligand Delta especially Delta four then
if you give the extract of the bone
marrow which would have common lymphoid
progenitor amount of T and B cells
eventually what you would see that in
the plate would be full of T cells that
means with increasing the knotch
in this supportive stomatal fill that
give rise to a signal into these
immature T cells or the immature common
lymphoid progenitor which would allow
the lineage commitment towards the T
cell now this in vitro experiments along
with these two in vivo genetic knockouts
is knock in knockout system tells us
that not signaling has a defined role to
play in terms of T cell lineage
commitment now let's look at the
signaling details in bits and pieces to
understand the process better so imagine
these are two cells the first one is the
timing epithelial cell in orange and the
blue one is the T cell and the precursor
T cell or the highly mature T cell which
is not committed yet now at this stage
it would express not at its surface
whereas the T cell timing epithelial
cell would Express tilt especially Delta
for the first step would be not still to
interaction simply the receptor ligand
interaction after receptor ligand
interaction what would happen is there
is a protease known as Adam which would
cleave the extracellular domain of the
notch and free extrasolar not to men and
the knot interacts with the Delta in
this situation the intracellular domain
is kind of now hanging from the membrane
with a transmembrane domain now further
there is another
proteus complex known as comma
securities which cut Cleaves these
transmembrane domain and free this
intracellular not not interested in the
domain and now the notch intracellular
domain is free to move to the nucleus
note that the Delta and not
extracellular domain is now endo sites
since I tossed by the other thymic
epithelial cell but let's focus on the
ni sealing once once NiCd is new clearly
localized it can interact with its
binding partner and several of them are
co-activators like mastermind CFL and CB
f1 all of these give rise to gene
transcription inside the immature T
cells and the top jeans that are
transcribed by this machinery is gata3
cycling d1 and scenic now Gayathri is
one of the master mind transcription
factors that help the T cell to commit
towards a T cell lineage now cyclin d1
and seeming as you can remember that
these are all important for cell cycle
progression and proliferation so this
not only help in the lineage commitment
but also help in the overall
proliferation of the T cell and that is
how T cell lineage get committed inside
the thymus at very early stage of the T
cell development so I hope you enjoyed
this video and it was informative if you
like this video you give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe do let me know how you
like my videos in the comment that would
give me a positive motivation to make
more such videos and keep watching thank
you